et maintenant
voici michel drucker
michel drucker très heureux de vous
avoir michel tellement heureux d'être à
ses côtés de lui pour plein de raisons
ça a été votre premier invité non aussi
longue histoire
ça fait presque quarante ans jour pour
jour qu'on a débuté ensemble devant les
caméras spiro du social c'était à doué
il y avait johnny en col mao qui
revenait d'une mauvaise passe et qui
chantait de noir c'est noir c'est noir
il y avait lui qui devait chanter moi et
moi il y avait un gars qui ressemblait
comme deux gouttes par françoise sagan
gaieté polnareff ce que qu'il y avait
daniel qui sentait les neiges du
kilimandjaro et la plage aux romantiques
il y avait les sharks si tu viens avec
les nerfs y avait un mec qui s'appelle
jean claude petit 1 excusez du peu près
ça à 40 ans johnny se demander si refait
surface
toi tu te demandes et riom permis aux
normales je me souviens qu'il y avait
une panthère à l'époque n'ont que des
excuses matthews poursuivrait toute ma
vie
on est rentré avec johnny et je suis me
disais ce que tu crois que la fia
surface et gilles il est de toute façon
la vitesse à laquelle tu vas on va
jamais refaire surface tous les bureaux
d'études voilà merci à fuir alors en
tous les cas nous il n'ya pas 40 ans
qu'on se connaît michel ça fait une
vingtaine d'années qu'on se croisant
dans le métier et puis a pas longtemps
l'année dernière j'ai organisé à un
repas chez moi au 93 rue du faubourg
saint-honoré et il y avait plein de
l'animateur comme ça qu'ils essayer
d'exister parce qu'on a tous un ego gros
comme une maison
et puis au bout d'un moment le calme
s'est installé autour de la table et la
voix de michel est resté j'ai découvert
ce soir là en fait que vous étiez le
le parrain quoi le godfather c'est par
sa fille un coup d'oeil aux saints n'ont
pas du tout pourquoi il ya des jeunes
par la mafia
alors juste que j'étais applaudissements
elle a été voir peuvent pas dire alors
ensuite on a débarqué tous les deux en
normandie effectivement on a en a seront
peut le dire je crois qu'on a sauvé la
france on a cela de vie c'était un grand
souvenir parce qu'il fallait être gonflé
merci quand même à ne pas trop curieuse
affaire baldelli et nous laisser faire
toute la nuit ensemble à lille en direct
tous les deux oui et ça marche ayant
plus voilà c'est pas évident de samedi
soir tu vois d'itron moi aussi j'ai des
souvenirs d'anciens combattants avec
drucker maintenant je suis heureux de
vous recevoir michèle aujourd'hui même
pas heureux dit la vérité je suis si
heureux de vous recevoir michèle parce
que c'est les 40 ans de france 2 lundi
voilà lundi donc et vous ça fait 40 ans
que vous faites de la télévision alors
il ya une grande émission qui est
diffusée lundi soir à 20h50 consacré aux
40 ans de la chaîne
on va regarder la bande annonce je vais
regarder votre caméra et vous avez dire
magnéto serge magnéto serge cals fans